Bladesmiths, this
is the strength test.
To test the strength and
durability of your edge
as well as overall
construction of your knives,
I'll be batonning your
blades into these motorcycle
handlebars three times.
Andy, you're up first.
ANDY: I am a little
concerned about chipping.
I've got more of a
feeling that this knife is
going to roll before it chips.
[music playing]
Well Andy, there is, on
my first hit down here,
a pretty significant roll.
You can get your
fingernail under it.
The second two hits, just
a slight, slight roll
right there.
The handle is a little bit
square for me, but it is solid.
In all, well done.
Thank you.
Jonathan, you're up next.
You ready?
Go for it.
JONATHAN: I'm really nervous.
I definitely think my knife
is going to take some damage
because I still don't know
enough about that steel
to know how it's going to react.
[music playing]
Well Jonathan,
first things first--
love this handle.
This thing is so comfortable.
It feels like it's kind
of just hugging me.
It's so wonderful.
More importantly though, man,
your edge held up beautifully.
There is some minor glinting
but very, very minor.
Very well done.
- Thank you.
Ed, are you ready?
Have at it.
Because it's about
to happen right meow.
ED: Motorcycles and knives
are two of my favorite things.
They're going to hurt
the bike and they're
going to hurt my knife, so
it's a double whammy, you know?
[music playing]
Well Ed, on the
first hit there
was a pretty significant roll.
You can hear it.
- Yeah.
The second two
strikes were much
less damaging to the blade.
I also like the overall
shape of your knife.
Well done.
- Thank you.
Next up, the
chopper seat slash.
To see how sharp your blades
are I will take your weapon
and slash across
these chopper seats.
Andy, you're up first.
You ready?
Sure.
Let's do it.
Let's ride.
[music playing]
All right, Andy, let's talk
about your blade right here.
Your edge, while it took
some damage, what's telling
is on some of the areas
that are not sharp anymore,
it kind of ripped parts of
that particular seat cover.
But overall, it will cut.
Thank you.
Jonathan, your turn.
You ready?
Let's hope so.
[music playing]
All right, Jonathan,
let's talk about your blade.
It is sharp.
From down here all the way
to the [inaudible] tip,
as I'm cutting, it digs
in to this chopper seat.
This blade, sir, it will cut.
Thank you.
Ed, it's your turn.
You ready?
Yeah.
[music playing]
All right, Ed, let's talk
about your knife right here.
Your handle, it
feels comfortable.
That finger weld right
there actually works.
Your blade right
here, despite taking
some damage in some
areas here, is razor
sharp on the other parts of it.
It lacerated deep on
the slashes horizontally
and also vertically.
It will cut.
- Thank you
The bladesmith leaving
the forge is Andy.
Your blade didn't make the cut.
Andy, we can really appreciate
your blade-making skills.
But in the strength test,
two blades took damage,
one of them being yours.
And your handle was the least
comfortable among all three.
For that reason, we're
sending you home.
Totally understand.